good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy wednesday happy
hump day is it really hum day if theo is
not here to
celebrate with us theo's not here i just
getting out of the house is it's a
journey no i don't blame you
it's such a journey i know i don't blame
you and i understand there's a million
reasons why
theo isn't here today it's just hard to
celebrate hump day to get into the
spirit of the holiday
when he's not here cheering us on no i
fully understand that but just just know
if you need someone to hump like i'm
always here for you you know what i
might take you up on that side
and if enough hump days go by without
theo in the mix watch out claudia
i just couldn't i just couldn't do it
today like it was just
getting out of the bat like waking up
and getting out of the house was
some days it's easier than others and
today it was really like an experience
yeah i i can understand that it's a
crazy day
right now i'm sure everyone was up late
watching
too close to call too close to call so
just don't [ __ ] talk about it it's
too close to call it's just torture
and we're here being tortured again so
where are we
nice to have patience so the morning
toast is the perfect distraction for you
it is while um these two close to call
races get closer to call
yeah it's but you guys really honestly
like it's too close to call
and that's that's the journey we're on
right now too close to call
so yes as jackie said we're going to
just distract you from our thing
our toasty thing it's wednesday which
means we have deer toasters which is a
favorite day of mine because deer
toasters that is our advice segment if
you're new here
if you ever want to write in you can
always email us dear toasters gmail.com
excited to see what you guys cooked up
for us today how we can help
your various situations i've heard that
they're quite weird today so
people find themselves in the most odd
predicaments we absolutely love to hear
that they're quite weird today
yeah and i never got an update on the
girl whose husband was eating his toes
and boogers during quarantine and if
you're still a listener and we didn't
like
really scare you with the way we went in
on your husband please write us in i
need an update what the [ __ ] is going on
are you okay are you still married is
your husband still a practicing attorney
does he still find a way to be an
acrobat and pick his toes
let us know we're very curious over here
at the morning toast
yes we are we have a great show for you
today
um oh you watch holiday yesterday did i
want to talk to you about it
i started to watch blackpink light up
the sky but then i fell asleep because i
created a vibe in my living room we were
on the phone yesterday trying to create
mutual vibes
and bruno and i fell asleep together on
the couch so um the blackpink
documentary had to wait
but i started and it was really good so
far i did try and cultivate a vibe in my
living room for those of you who know i
live in an apartment
and i've literally never sat on my couch
like i don't know her
at all like when can we have company
maybe but i pretty much like
in quarantine spend most of it in bed
and that's just been kind of toxic as of
recently
so yesterday i spent the majority of the
day in the living room with candles i
dim the lights i watched the holiday
and i'm still waiting on a few key
amazon deliveries in order to have my
vibe
be fully cultivated but i definitely
started it then when ben got
home he made a chili so we had like
something on the stove and so it was
really like a warm night and
a vibe was definitely cultivated i too
made a chili
and it was delicious yeah ben's was
really good
i'm sure ben's was really good mine is
the award loosening chili this is the
award-winning if you want to see how we
each make our chilis head over to
patreon.com
we have the great chili cook-off i guess
last night we had like a virtual chili
cook-off i'm sure ben's was still better
than mine
because you want to know why mine's
vegetarian no the chili that he made
last night was better than the chili he
made in the
coffee it was so good i should have
asked you to bring me some i know i have
a lot
[ __ ] sorry go home get it you can come
over and eat some if you want i might
it was so good i will do anything
for chili i [ __ ] love chili i
literally almost ate my whole vat of
chili last night i had like one small
tupperware left
it was the perfect thing to eat
throughout the night because like yeah i
had it as an appetizer as an
entree and then as a dessert and a
museum
but yes i did watch a holiday and i had
a lot of thoughts i thought it was like
a really cute sweet movie it was
definitely too long
told you that you would say that what is
farook from it was bothering me
so much i mean there's one simple simple
way to find out but he is an extremely
familiar man
and at first i was like honestly i don't
know how she's gonna choose farook is so
handsome and he's a doctor and like you
just didn't expect the guy that her
mother was trying to set her up with
to be so handsome but that guy is such a
cutie
he is from hold on
it's like you know i have to get to the
the one that you wrote
that we know oh wow he's in a lot of
stuff that i've never seen
he just looked so familiar he was in
90210
that's no that's not what i don't know
that's not gonna
satiate it's not gonna satiate okay wait
i'm going to his imdb because google
movies and tv shows like they never know
just read them maybe i've seen something
you haven't seen them in the resident
fast and furious 15 years later agents
of shield viceroy's house halt and catch
fire identity i'm obsessed with you but
you've got to leave me alone love that
for him
the 100-foot journey law and order oh
this view no it was like one episode uh
california scheming breaking the girls
or die switch up that's two different
things breaking the girls
or die die um switched at birth the
domino effect
90210 he's in a number of episodes no
the good wife star wars the call
no but no we're gonna we're gonna what
this you keep going yeah yeah hold on
um the box sorcerer's apprentice
whirling dervish carmichael i've never
heard any of this [ __ ] yeah no
i need to wet what is that it's
bothering me so much
no this is really maybe it is 90210 now
that i'm thinking about it it
does feel familiar i guess
no that's not it's just not enough for
me someone will let us know but wow that
there's nothing worse than that feeling
of not being able to put your finger on
where you know someone from and wait i
had that feeling also
in the opening scene when jackson goes
to that girl's house for christmas
yes you're hungry she's the roommate you
know what i
actually because she i couldn't place
her and so
i thought if i knew what her name was i
would be able to know so i actually sat
through
the cast at the end to get to her and i
got to her name and i still couldn't
figure it out but yes young and hungry i
know that one
i love i actually love that actress i
think she's so pretty but back to the
movie
here was what i thought that was very
cute like elevated
hallmark borderline rom-com netflix
movie big budget
um the movie honestly was like an
advertisement for chicago like it looked
so fabulous how every holiday like where
were these parties being held
that new year's eve party looked like so
glamorous the signature mayor party
looked so fun
all the bars it's like it wasn't too
packed it was like every party was like
perfectly planned the halloween party
i'm like
i need to live here where all these
fabulous holiday parties just magically
appear
yeah it was fabulous yeah like i need to
live in a world where like i
need to go to all these parties so i
need a holiday you know it's like
there's so many parties that i'm being
invited to that it's like overwhelming
and it takes up the whole year
yeah that was fabulous yeah so it was
cute
and she's so great she was great and
there was a there was a lot of
laugh out loud moments for for sure and
i was nervous because emma roberts is
like
a more serious actress but she's also
quite comedic scream queens well yes and
so i thought it might have the emily and
paris effect where like this elevated
actress comes to netflix to like kind of
play like a sillier role and just can't
handle it like lily collins
but i thought that emma roberts did a
great job i thought she looked so cute
the whole movie
the nicola pelts of it all was so funny
um i thought it was great it was really
really funny highly recommend definitely
got me in the holiday spirit while i was
you know cultivating my vibe it
definitely helped it added to the the
vibe cultivation
kristin chenoweth was great in it i
loved her relationship with her family i
just love a family film you know
yeah it was definitely a family film um
he's not here to speak for himself but
what did theo think of it
loved love loved it like watched the
whole thing he thought it was cute
he loved the scene at the end where the
choir was like jackson
oh yes that was so good yeah it had a
really cute moment
and i think like some of it was
trying to become like an iconic rom-com
like some of it was giving me like
friends with benefits vibe where it's
like it was
it had like these elements that were
like kind of like rom-com iconic do you
know what i mean
yeah no it was really good it could end
up there maybe
no i don't think that it it is going to
but no i think it's it's
a great netflix movie especially for the
holidays even though it's not super
holiday-centric well yes because then in
the first five minutes christmas was
over and i'm like
but i guess that's like last night it's
like easter yeah valentine's day
holidays like it's not um this holiday
yeah yeah it's all the
holidays it was really good i think i
would recommend great
yeah i would definitely recommend so
check it out if you haven't yet you're
two for two with your recommendations
this week
i don't know what i'm gonna watch today
i don't know what i'm gonna watch today
either i might
read oh i have to edit the redheads i'm
very busy oh the drama
drama the redheads so much drama it's
successful savings
so um anything else you watched
yesterday that you want to recap there
was no
tv on no the bachelorette was not on so
we'll see what goes down
next week after no fail i think it's on
thursday this year
i've heard that you're lying uh don't
quote me on that but i that's what i
think
i'm almost positive yeah yay yeah so
that's good
okay i can't wait yeah wait i'm so
excited
that's fine but thursdays are busy like
i'm busy i'm booked in busy car
no and like my mind like on a thursday
night like it's the weekend like i can't
be bothered to be doing work and the
bachelorette
is work two hours plus kardashians and
there's one other show on thursday yeah
i think um
not oc's tonight something like that
what are the uh
something oc like oh it's uh don't be
tardy's on no no no no no we're not
really
the one there's another show on thursday
nights i don't think so yes i i know
southern charm southern charm thank you
well we're really in the thick of like a
really busy tv schedule season yes so
clear your schedules
yep thursday night the bachelorette i
think okay let's hope you're ready let's
hope you're wrong i mean i usually
am but i'm really like it devastates me
to say like i think that i'm right
okay well without further ado i do think
that it's time to get into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and yes jacqueline that may be true but
you know what else is true
tell me you know what else is real hmm
you know what else is breaking up
families across
america what breath true
my house specifically is really getting
torn up by this breath pandemic
um and that's why we're so excited that
today's episode is brought to you by
thera breath
the world's fastest growing oral health
care solution because it really works
the founder is doc dr harold katz he
invented the first thera breath brush
fresh breath formula 25 years ago
they have an amazing line of products
here in studio we have the gum the mints
the mouthwash
it is just fabulous because one it's
like an oral healthcare brand so it's
like let's get our teeth right our gums
healthy
but their main focus is breath and for
me as someone who's very sensitive to
breath but also suffers from
really like duty breath more than i care
to admit
um their breath every every week these
ads get
more detailed because their breath is
just truly changing the name
and if you suffer from breath that
tastes like duty
or maybe your partner does i think it's
time to invest in
their breath system because it's
changing hearts and minds across this
country
they have um all of their products focus
on various health are you okay i'm
trying to get through that on various
oral health care issues like fresh
breath
bleeding gums and gingivitis anti-cavity
teeth straightening and improvement
strengthening and improvement and dry
mouth which is a real problem if you
have bad duty breath like me
it's sold everywhere target walmart
walgreens cvs rite aid
so much more um but also the best part
is that they're kosher all their
products are also
totally ethical and clean
vegan gluten free and kosher so our
jewish hall of french toasters feel free
to get on the thera breath train
be sure to check out therabreath.com
toast
and use the code a toast to save 25
off on their total order so that's
www.thera t-h-e-r-a-breath.com
toast and the promo code is a toast
a-t-o-s-t
to save 25 off on your order
thera-breath like therapy for your
breath
love it sign on combat your duty breath
yeah no i think they should really take
that on as an official slogan yeah we'll
submit it
yeah okay first story the news that
everyone is talking about in the country
maybe even the world
real housewives of beverly hills erica
jane and tom gerardi
break up after 21 years together and
hopeless romantics around the world are
devastated and heartbroken and a little
remiss yes
real houses of beverly hills star erica
jane is filing for divorce from her
husband tom girardi
after much consideration i've decided to
end my marriage to tom girardi the
reality star exclusively tells e news
this is not a step taken lightly or
easily i have great love and respect for
tom and for our years and
lives we built together it is my
absolute wish to proceed through this
process with respect and with the
privacy that both tom and i deserved
i request others give us that privacy as
well so
here's the thing there's like a big
conspiracy theory online
of people saying that you know tom as
the lawyer that he is and for years
we've known that him and his loss
firm have just been going through kind
of routine um lawsuits like they've
they're being sued um a lot of people
are saying
that you know tom is getting up there in
age and if he does
pass away she inherits those debts and
those lawsuits
and that her divorcing him kind of frees
her from that financial burden if
anything were to happen to him
so i think that actually is just people
being like hopeful that like there's no
love lost
i you know i'm sad because people had so
much to say about them but at the end of
the day i felt like
their marriage was like strong and it
spoke for them for itself and every
moment we got of them together was like
so earnest and sweet
and i just hate that like we're not
gonna have that
yeah i hadn't heard that conspiracy i
mean of course i hope that it's true and
it sounds like it makes a lot of sense
but on the one hand i'm like oh wow true
love is dead like
these two 21 years of marriage like
against all odds made it work like had a
wonderful life together
on the other hand i'm like yeah of
course like she's erica jane
of course like of course yeah like she's
doing her thing
so on the one hand i'm surprised on the
other hand like i'm not
it is surprising though that they would
make this announcement now while we know
that they're
filming because that makes it a
storyline whereas if she did it in the
off season it would be
less of a spectacle and less of
something for the women to talk about
which i do feel like she really values
her privacy
but you also have to think about how
when
when a housewife gets divorced and
their life traditionally before the show
was
rich man trophy wife your
priority shift almost overnight when yes
you probably get a settlement but you're
also now in charge of your own finance
and and
the show is such a big part of that so
you want to invest
in and they've been saying erica is
going to be a friend of housewife
there's a lot of rumors about her maybe
not being a full-time castmate
so it's like her job is up in the air
also while the stability of tom
and she can maybe make one serve the
other right so that's just
all speculation i'm sure tom is you know
very generous and
she'll be totally fine yes for the
record they do not have a prenup
um she had told that to andy pretty much
saying that even if they had a prenup
like tom is
assured lawyer he would yeah that's
right to shreds like it wouldn't stand
so that's just probably something a lot
of people wanted to know no i definitely
wanted to know that because like
i think a lot of people forget because
she's like erica jane but erica girardi
is actually one of the most wealthiest
housewives on that
show they have two planes that placed in
pasadena is huge like
they are super rich i would say she's
probably
she's richer than kyle she's who's the
richest on that show now
sutton she has two planes sutton
charters i don't know
i think it does make you think but like
sutton's just one woman like i think
erica has two plays like because of her
husband's business yeah but
while they're still married they count
just as much as such so does erica get
one plane
tom gets the other plane yeah you know
but keeping up a plane is
so expensive that like even if you're
super rich like sometimes it's just
easier to charter so you have to pay the
fees for the pilot and stuff which might
explain sutton
yeah no of course and if i was sudden
like my kids are grown i think and
i'm like a woman with a boyfriend like
i'm chartering i'm not being tied down
to a hanger
can you imagine so this is really sad
news no um and unexpected timing
yeah but you know what becoming a
housewife and the success that it
provides
for these women like really does change
marriages yes that's what melissa gorga
said on our show once and i never forgot
it she was like
and sometimes for the better sometimes
for the worse sometimes indifferent but
it's just a shift
right it happened for her and joe too
it's like you're you spend your whole
life your whole marriage being like
a mom a housewife picking up the kids
cleaning the house making dinner
and then overnight you're like a success
and you have this whole career and like
those priorities just shift and the
husbands are like wait what the [ __ ]
happened
where's my dinner and it does affect a
lot of marriages and i think that her
and joe like
got through it really really well but
some people it's just like
such a shift that it breaks them yeah
and you just
are a different person than you were
beforehand and those two people did not
grow together so
it's not always like the worst sad thing
i don't think anything
nefarious happened to you me neither i
just i don't know
i i'm just sad like i'm taking it really
hard and i'm gonna
hold off on feeling any other emotion
until like whatever see
the season comes out and like erica
explains it to us and not that we
need an explanation but just like you
know she's the one who filed for divorce
so i wonder what she's looking for and
what she wasn't receiving i'm also
really excited at the prospect of erica
jane on the dating scene
like she's a big time celeb she's
beautiful
she could really just brad pitt i don't
know she could get whoever she wants
she's fabulous yeah that'll be exciting
still tom i'm gonna miss seeing him once
the season oh my god same no no i'm
taking this
really hard like his support like him
showing up to like the club
to watch his wife perform and just like
hugging her and like really like i'm
honestly gonna cry like being so proud
of her like
that's really all you could hope for and
a partner like someone who just like
lets you do your thing doesn't like
judge you and like just wants the best
for you and i'm really taking this very
hard
yeah me too because i love tom and i
want him to be happy and erica but i
feel like
tom loves erica so much i feel like tom
loves erica more than erica loves tom
and 21 years of marriage is a long-ass
time so you always mourn when something
like that comes to an end because it's
sad
yeah it's very sad damn i'm so upset
like there's
i'm sorry i'm really upset
we'll keep you posted if we hear
anything else hopefully the conspiracy
theory is true
hopefully yeah that's something to hold
on to like they're still in love but
legally just like they think it's best
not to be married
next up dancing with the stars judge
carrian inauba is being bullied by fans
carry an inaba tells it like it is and
won't be stopping anytime soon
the dancing with the stars judge said
she was cyberbullied for her pointed
critique
of caitlyn and artem's jive performance
on november november 2nd
she said i still get bullied right about
this time is when people start to bully
me because of the way i judge people
i can't believe it still happens as
adults many fans took issue with the
judge docking bristow
and shig points this week due to what
she considered an illegal lift
during their routine she said i want to
tell people who bully
it doesn't make me change the way i
judge i'm not about to change because
you try to bully me
it only makes me stand stronger in my
convictions and what i believe in
so i'm actually like not a carry an
anaba fan but i actually really
respected this like
very candid response to people like
we're all adults it's a tv show and like
you're literally bullying me on social
media because you don't like what i have
to say like get over yourself
and not only that you're not changing my
mind if anything i'm going to be even
meaner
because of you guys on social media so
we actually really respected that
but i do think there are valid um
critiques
from the audience just in terms of a how
carrie anne like
chooses people to kind of like pick on
and i think in her mind she sees it as
like mentorship but
i think everyone else just sees it as
like being picked on and i
i kind of wish she would address that
because the whole scoring system on
dancing with the stars
is so [ __ ] or in the words of emma
roberts cockamamie like
it just it makes no [ __ ] sense
there's no like standard
it's just like every week it's like you
it just makes no sense
so while i actually really respect this
decision i mean this response i do wish
you would actually address some of the
valid
concerns and critiques about her judging
got it and i don't think that's an
unfair statement i don't think that's
unfair i do like her response also
not like just because you don't like
what i'm doing doesn't make me
do what you want me to do yeah and then
just like the broad picture like we are
all grown-ass people like watching a
television show like
it ain't that serious celebrities
dancing no it's like
it's so interesting no and sometimes you
just need that kind of perspective to
see how [ __ ] insane you're yeah like
look at caitlyn bristow's outfit here so
cute so cute
it's not that serious you know it's just
like it's a fun show it's meant to be
lighthearted and
good time family friendly and it's like
these people who like
literally oh my god that reminds me i
wanted to make a huge shout out to
heather mcdonald she is a host of juicy
squid podcast i'm sure a lot of you guys
know her
she posted the [ __ ] funniest thing on
her instagram yesterday
she got an email from like a long time
viewer just the viewer basically like
saying she's done with juicy scoop like
heather you know it was really like
unclear
what her gripe was what her gripe was
but she was like accusing heather of
like dressing [ __ ] like it was and
being pornographic
it was so bizarre and the girl
accidentally left her phone number
woman grown woman left her phone number
in the um
signature of the email so heather
decided to call her and just she's like
i'm not one to let a customer go and she
tried to like salvage this
it was so [ __ ] funny and i had so
much respect heather posted the
whole conversation on her ig tv it was
so funny
and it really gives you perspective into
like this woman when she picked up the
phone and it was heather mcdonald she
was overjoyed she's a huge
fan and then she was like oh i'm sorry i
was in a bad mood like that's my own
[ __ ] and it's like
what it's so delusional
that i could it was a brilliant social
experiment it was
and i really like applaud heather
because it's very scary like
confronting someone who [ __ ] hates
you it was so good and so funny and if
you
want to go watch it it's on our
instagram and that's the whole thing
here it's like
look how bent out of shape we're getting
over people we don't know right we've
got and i know i said this earlier in
the week
we've got to start running our business
and we've all seriously got to calm down
like
take it down like 10 notches yes agreed
mad respect that video is
hysterical yeah she's so funny she
really is
okay next story is some exciting news i
think for you
for a friend's lover and a makeup lover
okay because there's a new friends
makeup collection
at ulta and it's bound to sell out just
as quickly as the first now i want
you to take a look at some of these
photos if claudia likes them maybe we'll
share them to our instagram later like
if she thinks that anyone would care
enough too let's see these products
it's a coffee cup i don't know how
there's like a lip gloss it's like
friends
iconography no i see so there's there's
ulta there's a
looks like a tub of eucerin moisturizer
with a pink cap that says central perk
you've got to moisturize
then there's a lip gloss that says ross
on it which makes no [ __ ] sense and
has
little monkeys on the cap which is
obviously marcel
um then oh this oh this is cool there is
a
5 10 15 18 shadow palette where
can i see the colors yeah where the um
oh that's
that's pretty cool the design is
monica's door it's the purple door with
the yellow frame around it you know the
one from vanderpump rules
yes then oh there's another cool oh this
is cool it's by oh so it's not ulta it's
makeup revolution but it's being sold
at ulta yeah there's another palette
looks to be like 20
15 shades uh that's a yellow cab which
isn't really friends and also this is
like if
this is a cab from like the 50s so
um i don't know how that relates oh and
then there's another makeup that has a
lobster on it that's cute he's your
lobster
oh and another eyeshadow palette we'll
definitely post these on our instagram
that's a
big black coffee mug like that says
central perk on it
that's cute oh i love those colors yeah
those look good um then there's more oh
i guess there's lip glosses for everyone
so
phoebe's has the lobster design on it
monica's has the
door frame design on it and rachel's has
the central perk logo which doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense
then there is loose powder and
moisturizer that just has central perk
on it
it's cute i mean would you buy any of it
makeup revolution actually
it's like a great drugstore brand not
well without my eye
sorry i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying it
freaking out
makeup revolution actually is a fabulous
uh drugstore brand very reasonably
priced
and great formulas so if i were to
recommend i don't know if i would get
the lip glosses they look really shitty
i would get some of the eyeshadow
palettes and i'm really looking forward
to
that next story no kidding what to do
with my hands
um okay cool so i'm glad you're looking
forward to it like i don't know if to me
like the show friends squeeze screams
like makeup or glamour
but i i appreciate create creativity in
all forms even when it comes to
highlighting shows that are in no shape
way or form funny
oh [ __ ] the other thing is like
whoever whoever owns the rights to like
friends
and like the logos like they are not
letting this
cash cow die like they keep doing they
did a
collab with coffee bean they celebrate
every year anniversary like merch
it's like one of the highest grossing
shows of all time and they don't stop
coming up with new revenue streams
closing line with bloomingdale's
remember like the rachel clothing no i
don't but that's cool okay but this
coffee mug eyeshadow palette is actually
stunning
that's like those are the colors that i
use it's like nudes light browns
caramels
is it caramel or caramel caramel me too
there's
fully in a so i don't know why people
are just like just gonna skip over it
caramel
is actually the name of a car service
here in new york and it's spelled
c-a-r-m-e-l
carmel yeah but i'm just saying like
people who say six
six six six six they actually have like
a borderline anti-semitic remember six
oh my god they really commercial that
runs and i just have to say like i
actually use carmel all the time like i
think it's a great business and spite
their fragrant anti-semitism
i'm not trying to like slander them
because also my
favorite car company just went out of
business that i used to take from the
airport groundlink i'm so upset
so now i'm using carmel and they have
this commercial that has been running
for a few years and i just want to say
like
as a jew like and i'm really not
offended by much like
i'm definitely offended by this
commercial they're like what are you
meshegna and then it's just like
it's google it it's literally like so
[ __ ] anti-semitic and i can't believe
more people don't talk about it
but like now it's kind of like endearing
i don't know it's very bizarre
um because it's a new york-based company
it's just like know your audience you
know
yeah no it's definitely a strange thing
we just sort of allow to happen
yeah i don't know how we got here from
friends but um
i'm not mad because i've been meaning to
talk about that but sugar in a
commercial for a while
six six six if you need some concepts
and medicare services
caramel that's how we got here but if
you do need to use the anti-medicare
service you should call
666 6666
remember six driving to the airport
right oh that wasn't they had a good
commercial with that one
go to the airport number six riding
around town
call call now shopping or movies
remember six the best ride in town for
wherever you want to go
carmel is the number no
ride carmel and beyond time worldwide
and nationwide six six six six six sixty
six
remember six yeah that was a good
commercial then they obviously hired a
new creative director who hates jews
and they came out with what are you
messing
up no you don't understand the dial six
songs slaps
yeah any if this episode gets to anyone
at carmel and i have a feeling that it
will i hope so go back to those
commercials and i'll be dialing six
yeah no and that was like in new york
and this is a very niche conversation
okay this is very okay in new york
there's two there's like a
very heated competition between
dial six and dial seven and
to be honest dial seven has been around
longer and i just think more people know
like you call a taxi seven seven seven
seven seven
yeah what's their sorry it's like they
have a song
no they have the guy yelling in the
middle of the street um
when when he can't get a taxi to the
airport
okay whatever i watch way too much tv
but all i'm saying is that
for a while dial six really had that
song over dial seven and i think that
like that's when dial six became a real
you know new york staple when they had
that 666 but then they decided to
transition into
you know anti-semitic propaganda and i
do think
that that changed things okay but wait
there is a dial 7 song and dial 7 is
carmel
right no that sounds sick jackie you
guys
see each other dial seven is called dial
seven and you're right
when dial six came out with their smash
their
banger dial seven tried to replicate it
with their own sad version and it will
train brent morgan does anyone want to
hear it yeah
hold on if i hear it
oh this is beautiful
it was too late though dial 6 had a race
still in people's hearts
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i've never heard this but it's a
wasted commercial because it's so good
that is
and you know what that stops and you
know what i don't hear any anti-semitic
propaganda in there and i don't mind
that we're not going to be able to
monetize this
yeah no we totally just got to monetize
on youtube because dial 7 is coming for
us
yeah but no actually i think in the
battle between six and seven like we've
just taken seven sides
which is so good though six six six no
but honestly
for me it always comes down to price and
quality of car
and six is superior in my opinion
yeah i guess i would go six but it's
only because that song's stuck in my
head
yes but i guess next time you guys are
in the city
dial six dialogues once and then dial
seven let us know which what you think
yeah let's do a poll
okay next story in some relatable news
travis scott has deleted his instagram
account to focus on his family
so travis scott did not delete his
instagram over the weekend because of
trolling comments aimed at his batman
costume as some people thought he might
what is he 12 and who thought that but
he deactivated his social media because
he's focusing on his family which
includes his two-year-old
daughter stormy webster and his pregnant
wife kylie
icon queen went her first day of school
in a 12 000
backpack and that's something that needs
to be focused on um yeah so it
definitely feels like kylie's maybe
having morning sickness
and um travis needs to be there for her
and this is all just tracking in
in my predictions i just i actually
really love this story
i think that social media is like a
toxic wasteland
and and when celebrities get like so
caught up in it
it normalizes it so beloved and so
successful and it's like oh
they too like can't stay away from the
drama and need to delete it to focus on
their family like
i just feel like that's something that
we can all relate to yeah and cardi b
has actually been pretty vocal about
that
specifically on twitter she like deletes
her twitter every week because people
are just so [ __ ] nasty
and i really like when celebrities talk
about it because we all talk about like
social media is tax
yeah but then we're all still on it 24
7. i like when they
walk the walk yeah in addition to
talking
i think it's fabulous so i'm not it's
not fabulous that for whatever reasons
he had to take a break but
normalize taking a break normalize it
okay
our fifth and final story in a little
bit of what the [ __ ] the kids are up to
what the [ __ ] are they up to tick tock
star zoe laverne is apologizing for
kissing her 13 year old fan
a 19 year old tick tock star is facing
backlash after a leaked video showed her
kissing a 13 year old fan
when they were just and when they just
ended up catching feelings for each
other
zoe laverne zoe laverne who has nearly
18 million followers on tick tock
apologized in a live stream this week
for her actions
but denied grooming the young fan and
fellow tick-tocker
named connor whose name has been
withhold due to his age
because he's 13. she said i didn't groom
connor i wouldn't do that he's a kid and
i'm aware of that it just happened
we were both in a dark place when we
first became friends and we both just
ended up catching feelings for each
other
and friends do that they catch feelings
for each other how old is she
she's 19 and he's 13. wow that's that's
deeply disturbing
she said it's not a bad thing yes the
age is a bad thing yes it's wrong yes
it's not good we both realized
that and we stopped i feel really weird
reporting on this i thought it was
really weird too but like i saw it
a lot of people are talking about it
like you had heard about it i know it's
all over
my free page and this girl has 18
million fans and i just feel like that's
a lot
no and like this is just like this is so
disgusting
so disgusting and people are
rightfully outraged i just don't know
how we got here
like no how did how was this what we're
talking about
like it's really disturbing and
the kids have gone wild that's all there
is to say
yeah okay
it's just [ __ ] gross it's not funny
like it's just [ __ ]
like sick the kids are just
wild yeah all right now we're gonna jump
into
deer toasters i just really like wanted
a toaster strudel right now i just
because
when you like visualized your toasters i
see like two pop-tarts like popping out
of the
toaster delicious that's like my visual
aid and now i'm starving i've just been
so hungry i've been eating so much
good you know like we need to nourish
our souls yeah
that's true um and so our tier toasters
segment is brought to you by athletic
greens if you're looking for one product
that has as much high quality nutrients
in it as possible
then you want to consider athletic
grains with as many as 75 minerals
vitamins and whole foods sourced
ingredients
you'd be hard-pressed to find a more
nutrient-dense formula on the market
it has a multivitamin multimineral
greens complex probiotic
prebiotic for god health and immunity
formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and more there's no need for
multiple pills or complex routines
so filling the nutritional gaps in your
diet is as easy as one scoop of athletic
grains it's the multivitamin that goes
the extra mile
it helps with your immune system support
and your gut health support
athletic athletic greens is the most
recommended nutritional habit
making it easy to get high quality
nutrients on a daily basis
they make it easy with their super
superior taste absorption and easy to
use
subscription and it's important to
remember that not all vitamins are
created equal
athletic greens invest in its
ingredients so you can invest in your
health
we are obsessed with the ingredient
selection that optimizes for the
nutrient absorption
and they only choose the best
bio-available
forms of each vitamin mineral and whole
food-sourced ingredient
all their products are clean and green
constantly audited and tested to ensure
what's on the label
is in the powder and there's no harmful
chemicals no gmos
no additional additives so if you're
looking to upgrade your multivitamin or
take one nutritional formula that's
going to help you re
cover help cover your daily nutritional
basis then you don't want to con then
you want to consider athletic grains
athletic greens makes getting as much
high quality nutrition as possible
incredibly easy
without the need to buy multiple
products make an investment in your
health today and try the ultimate
all-in-one wellness bundle and support
your immunity gut health and energy by
visiting
athleticgreens.com toast you'll receive
up to a year's supply of liquid d
vitamin for free with your purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com
toast check it out dear toasters if you
ever want to write in your toasters at
gmail.com is it completely anonymous
email you can change names we'll
never use your name and you can write
tests about anything just like this girl
did
hey jackson claude hey longtime listener
here honestly my best friend and i are
obsessed with the both of you thank you
so we had to get the opinion of two
beautiful stunning and smart icons in
this situation
behold your ears because things are
about to get weird for the past two
months my three friends and i have hung
out pretty much every weekend and slept
over
my best friend's house she has a queen
bed so obviously all four of us can't
fit in the bed
the first time we all stepped over i
slept on the couch as any sane person
would because i was not going to be
squished
in the bed the next weekend i made it a
fact that i was not sleeping on the
couch again and it was someone else's
turn
my one friend who was 20 volunteered to
sleep with my best friend's younger
brother who's 15.
what is going on with the kids today who
was 15. you're probably thinking what
the [ __ ] but just wait
let's rewind a little here and give you
the backstory over the past couple
months she has made little comments to
him like
do you think i have a nice butt am i
your type she also sat on his lap but
when the car was full but easily could
have squished in the back with the three
of us
since this has happened she slept with
him and not once but four times with the
door closed
what do we say to end this or simply
address this issue we need your help
girlfriend four times this is truly
unacceptable and this is really [ __ ]
weird ass behavior and you need to stop
hanging out with this girl
and you seriously need to stop letting
her in your house and in your little
brother's room this is really [ __ ]
weird
this is really weird really
inappropriate call the police no
literally
like and why are you friends with this
person that is the absolute strangest
thing
i've ever heard no no this is so bizarre
so inappropriate no it's illegal this is
weird with the door closed i'm very
uncomfortable with this information i
wish i did not read this
you have got to step in yeah zillow
kavod as we say
not nice oh okay next
hello jackson claude how you doing i've
recently found worse now thanks yeah
terrible actually thanks for asking i've
recently found myself in a serious
pickle let me back up one year last
labor day i met a very attractive and
sexy man in nashville over labor day
weekend he was so nice and cute and we
have someone kept in contact since then
fast forward to now i now have a
boyfriend who is also sexy and fabulous
and i like him a lot
recently the nashville boy reached out
and typically when he does reach out
it's just a
hey how are you hope things are well
type of thing this time it was hey would
you like to send me
feet pictures i was drunk when i got the
message so i jokingly said yes thinking
he was kidding
he has now been asking me for free picks
in exchange for money for a week and he
even offered to pay me for a pedicure
should i do it i kind of feel slimy
sending a guy he picks for money when i
have a boyfriend but on the other hand
who doesn't want some extra dough and
what is harm please give me any and all
advice to this uncharted
terror toe rate for me i just have to uh
sincerely a torn toaster
i just have to say like i know this is
weird but we're living in unprecedented
times like you've just got to do what
you got to do to make money and i don't
really think that this is so crazy
um is that crazy like i think that if
you didn't have a boyfriend i would be
like whatever send the pics
like get a pedicure you know treat
yourself
but like because you have a boyfriend
like talking to a former fling and
sending him
photos that are probably turning him on
is inappropriate and cheating so
if you want a pedicure like and you
don't want to pay for it try
ask your boyfriend first be like hey
like you like dee's feet no i don't know
i want to put a little money towards him
i don't know if it's cheating because
he's getting sexual pleasure from it and
she's not
she's just getting money no but like she
is engaging in an inappropriate
relationship
outside of her existing relationship how
serious is this relationship like
you know do you think he's the one i
just think feet picks are a slippery
slope especially when you like know the
person and you're not just like selling
them on the internet
to an unknown person yeah but then at
the same time i don't think that she's
ever gonna realistically be attracted
to this man if she knows he's like a
feet foodie
no no i don't think that she's gonna
like be wooed by his foot fetish
but like it's inappropriate behavior
outside of the confines of your
relationship
also like to send feet picks for the
price of a
pedicure like i'd raise your price no he
said he would pay for the pedicure
and the feed picks it sounds like he's
being very gracious very generous
oh a generous benefit i just think we
shouldn't like just brush this
uh opportunity away from this job
opportunity you know what
opportunity only knocks once and i think
that you might
want to dip your toe in or maybe like do
it once see how it feels
yeah if you if you feel icky afterwards
and you're not uncomfortable don't ever
do it again block his number delete the
text
maybe if the price is right like you and
your boyfriend like you let him know and
you're like i have this opportunity once
in a lifetime right and then you start a
business together
yeah and then he's like helping buff
your toenails moisturizing your feet
getting them all shiny setting up the
lighting you take the pictures you get
the best
it's a joint venture i think that's your
best bet honesty and cash
yeah because if you start sending feet
pics behind your partner's back like
that's where
you're the dishonesty is the problem
yeah that's where you're getting into
trouble so i would just
i think honesty is the best policy
especially when you're conflicted and if
this is your boyfriend and you guys are
you trust him and you love him like
his opinion he might be able to provide
some advice and feet angles that you
couldn't find before yeah i know it's
very hard to photograph your feet
especially if you have a big belly like
me like
like i could barely give myself a
pedicure without throwing out my back i
can't imagine how i would get a feet
picture and i'm not
i'm not familiar with um the industry
fetishes yes
but do they like you know the soul of
the foot the top
i feel like they like toes toes they
wouldn't like mine
no i any time i post a picture on
instagram where you can see my foot
people are like your toes are [ __ ]
excuse me literally
jackie's same i don't know if you guys
know i'm releasing a book in january
26th
and um not 2026 january 21st
in five years so january 26 2021
available for pre-order at the link in
my bio on girl with the job instagram
and girls no job.com
um that's my foot you see it yeah that's
a nice foot it ain't mine
i literally have like crazy toes that
all look different ways
and when i got the book cover and we did
all the edits i was like about to be
like approved
and then i saw my toes and i'm like you
guys you've got to give me a different
foot
and shout out to the art department for
really killing this is a beautiful toe
i feel like people actually might buy my
book just so they could jerk off to my
foot and you know just like zoom in they
might buy it like a sale is a sale
they might buy a digital copy yes or
they could zoom so they consume
well the ebook is available at on amazon
audible as well you can't see my foot on
audible but yes ebook
um available you know nationwide yeah i
think we have like genetic
weird actually i i think my toes are
beautiful i think all toes are beautiful
i think that like we actually do have
like the genetics where the
second toe the second toe is a little
bit longer well that's just something
cute about us
and that's what's funny about the movie
shallow hal is when george costanza
won't date that girl even though she's
like stunningly beautiful because her
second toe
is taller than her first and like as a
kid i was like so was mine
and then on my left foot which is
actually the foot on the book cover my
fourth toe
just kind of like doesn't have a bone in
it it's like crazy rogue
no it like sometimes gets stuck under my
middle toe and it's like
ow do you have that tip yes and when the
nail's too long it like digs
ben thinks it's so wild like he cannot
get over it
oh i didn't know you had that too and i
also have a freckle on the back of my
right middle toe and margo has a freckle
in the same spot
whoa all right last year toasters hello
jackie and claudia first of all i just
want to say i love you guys so much and
i'm so glad your puppy family is growing
oh my god thank you so much that means
the world we're
we're thrilled and ecstatic ourselves
yeah she's here and she's beautiful
i've been dating my boyfriend for a year
now and i'm having some problems he's
such a gentleman and i love him with my
whole heart
one thing that has been bothering me
though is the fact that he doesn't post
anything with me on social on any social
media platform
stories posts etc we recently did a fun
little photo shoot in the city and we
got a ton of cute pictures i posted a
few they were so cute
i asked if he planned to post something
he told me that he didn't know which
picture to post and he asked his two
sisters
after asking them the two sisters told
him not to post a picture with me
because his larger family living abroad
will judge him
what excuse me his parents don't care
and no he is dating me but the rest
what's wrong with you
the rest of his family does not know
because they would not approve of our
relationship we're not from the same
religion i understand what it's like to
have a very judgmental family as my
family is the same but i've learned that
as long as i'm happy and my parents are
well nothing else matters
he showed me the group chat with his
sisters and i believed him when he told
me he wanted to do it but i am just a
little upset
there are girls who hang out with his
friends who don't know the full truth
and try to hit on him because they think
he doesn't care about the relationship
since he doesn't post anything with me
please help honestly the first steps is
going to be like oh girl like who cares
like boys don't really post on social
media
but this is more layered yeah and it's
indicative of a larger issue which we've
just
uncovered yeah and so i think the two of
you need to like
reconcile that piece of your
relationship and make the decision after
a year you know that is
like [ __ ] or get off the pot time and
make the decision if you guys are
committed to each other
ready to take on some of the judgments
from
each of your families and to stand
together against it
and i think eventually whatever decision
that you make
the social media posts will follow will
follow
but it seems like that's something that
you guys both need to get on the same
page about
yeah i feel like in situations like this
it's not uncommon for the girl to be
more kind of progressed in like
her independence and like not caring
what people think whereas like boys are
still
kind of behind in that sense so i
wouldn't feel bad that you're in this
situation because i think a lot of women
have been in this situation too
i just think how you handle it is and
what do you want to happen you want to
be together with this man
and so you got to put it out there like
he if he doesn't know how can you blame
him
yeah you have to confront the issues
assume and
and first decide like what outcome you
really and truly want
and i just want to say like i think
enough with the sisters like you're
posting on your instagram you to consult
your sisters about it
that sounds like an unhealthy boundary
sorry yeah but i wouldn't get so hung up
on the social media aspect like
same because that's just symptomatic of
the conflict going on and this conflict
can be resolved
yes you guys just both have to have a
tough conversation and
decide like what you want for your
futures and if you talk to him about it
and like you make it all about the post
he's just gonna be like oh girls in
social media
yeah you really have to spell it out for
him like it's not about that and that
will come
once you resolve the actual problem at
hand here which is
the religion the family the kind of
weird uh purgatory that you're in yeah
where are we taking this thing
where are we going duty i hope it works
out though me too
um love conquers all those were some
great deer toasters again if you ever
want to write in you are
always welcome to email us dear toasters
gmail.com
and it is always kept anonymous and we
can change people's names if you want
and if you've written us in the last
couple weeks and want to update us on
what happened
please we would really appreciate that i
love updates we'd love to hear from you
you know what we like never get updated
i'm just gonna take it as a sign no news
is good news
i agree everything worked out no it's
like my husband and i are so
happy together and we trust each other
so much
yeah we're just on our honeymoon again
you know i believe we take a break from
social media because we're so so happy
um that is our show for you guys we hope
you enjoyed it
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love take care of yourselves
and have a snack chili
now you have to tag us in your chilis i
use meat jackie did not so there's
options for everyone
so i've made this chili about four times
in quarantine now and i think i'm ready
to graduate to a new chili recipe
sorry martha stewart it took me like 30
minutes i know i just i'm like weird
about cooking
i know you are like i'm like definitely
afraid of like raw meat
it's [ __ ] gross it's gross and and
i'm just like
i always am so concerned that i don't
cook the meat enough that i overcook it
and i like waste good meat i don't know
i feel that it's tough i feel that way
about eggs too
i [ __ ] hate eggs like i think they're
literally the most disgusting [ __ ]
things ever
slimy little [ __ ] slimy and like only
you know only at like a very nice hotel
do i feel like eggs are made well but
like
usually they're like a runny and so
yellow and it's like it's [ __ ] sick i
think eggs are so disgusting and like
when you make them at home they're
either
burnt to a crisp or like runny and um
i've always been scared of runny eggs
yeah oh and not to mention it's like
literally eating fetuses like there's
just something weird about it okay well
that part no thank you but now that i've
been on
trying to do low carb i've been eating a
lot of eggs
and it never gets easier no it doesn't
but that's our show you guys hope you
have an amazing day thank you so much
for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know
every monday through friday on youtube
so if you're watching us on youtube
please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box we're now available on
amazon music
wherever you listen to podcasts search
the morning toast find us and maybe
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are i
don't know just a suggestion
hope you have an amazing day take care
of yourselves don't forget to wear a
face mask and we will see you tomorrow
make it chilly goodbye goodbye goodbye
you